water
long ago the three seasons live together
in harmony but then everything changed
when the Shan rule only the added jerk
master of ripping films apart to restore
balance but when the world needed him
most he vanished
several years passed and my brother and
I discovered the new avatar a reviewer
named nostalgia critic and although his
critiquing skills are great he still has
much to learn before he can save
anything but I believe nostalgia critic
can save the franchise
you
concentrate critic absorb every episode
of Avatar The Last Airbender to review
the movie why can't I just watch the
shows again it would take too long and
the franchise has suffered enough at the
hands of the fuckup Lord Shyamalan
that's why you need to get in contact
with a past-life to see if any of them
have seen the show
thus absorbing it into your memory I
mean like a you should absorb an affair
stylist ah you know my vocal opening was
supposed to be taboo like nobody should
have that unlimited control well M night
Shyamalan keeps getting unlimited
control and nobody's stopping him that's
true
now concentrate harder wait
hey I think I'm getting yeah I think I'm
getting visions from another life I'll
just go through an episode of the night
it's just the right balance avatar my
boo favorite show still one of my
favorite shows my god it's coming to me
ingenious writing brilliant characters
and a fan beats obsessing over name
pronunciation rather than the meaning of
each episode by God it's coming to me
got it critic yes avatar is one of the
greatest TV series of all time
good now you're ready to review the
up Lords disaster opus but wait just
because I know about doesn't mean the
people at home know about it how we
gonna catch them up to speed Katara
Katara
go to this point if you haven't seen the
show you owe for nation's success call
earth wind fire and water to fire
decided things should get hotter
invasions are nice but then to break the
icing the Avatar rose to make them pay
the price Katara and Sokka helped him to
keep in the mill flying what looks like
a white neighbor totoro chased by
therefore it seems to code don't ask oh
about a Scarl Rufio
the avatar masters the elements flawless
the toughest of toss turns a blind eye
so cautiously avatar State opens at a
great rate but Azula sources arrow des
on a plate Katara REE bison and they
think their love song but to go decide
to see her she's gone too long he
switches sides the turn of the top now
Aang is on fire with his smoking guy
Katara and Zuko beat Azula on the cat
mostly because she's overcome a lot
thanks filling you because you don't
want to kill but the Cowardly Lion
Turtles pencils down he's given the gift
to depower the Fire Lord nation says go
complete the work going live happily
the world lettuce we just remember that
it sinks the Baldy so that is the
showing is good that you know because it
is the bestest Cooper's who's just going
so mad at you her go ahead his friend
aware that the best I'm sorry that blue
turn
so judging by the beginning the film
actually looks pretty promising
reenacting the visuals to the show's
intro rather flawlessly even the tech
scroll isn't really that bad though how
is it a season with 20 episodes can get
their backstory out faster than an
hour-and-a-half movie Ken
the avatar was the only person born
amongst all the nations who could master
all four elements and then a hundred
years ago he just disappeared but sadly
we witness the greatest weakness of any
Shyamalan film
they start talking my brother and I live
in the Southern Water Tribe which was
once a big city food is scarce my
brother and I often go hunting for food
yeah way to use food twice in the same
sentence Academy Award nominated writer
our fathers are fighting in the war my
mother was taken prisoner and killed
when I owned this bar bending you're
witnessing is being performed by
siblings of the Water Tribe named Katara
and Sokka and yes the climate is looking
much wider than usual and I don't think
taking away the snow is gonna fix that
any this is curious as in the show
Katara and Sokka definitely seemed to
have an inuit design and that makes
sense their upbringing is very similar
to Eskimo culture strangely enough the
rest of the village seems to have this
down but with these two I think Kathy
beets from North was a more convincing
fake Eskimo but I'm not here to judge
the color of their skin only the quality
of their acting and I'm sure these two
acted so well that they just seemed
perfect for the part like nobody else
could do it better
maybe we can overlook the color
difference and see past all that wats
what side of the fin tracks are more
indented that shows you which direction
they're going I saw how long the drug's
gets are though they both succumb to the
dreaded Hayden Christensen syndrome no
one is taking anybody away please wait
here what could you do aren't there
spirits here they were looking for
someone with same markings stop it your
mother told you break glass are you the
avatar on
but they come across something while
hunting something under there it's a
good movie trying to get out kill it
they discover a boy named Aang
frozen in an iceberg along with his
where the wild things are mascot and
take him back to the village so if this
kids acting just as bad as the other two
does Shyamalan like awkward shots where
people look directly into the camera
how'd she get all the way out here I ran
away from home we got in a storm
it wasn't very smart I was just upset
thanks for saving lucky I probably
should get home you're not so upset not
as much as I want okay seriously am i
watching a school play this all seems
like a school play I mean I know they're
kids I shouldn't be so harsh but did
anybody give these little pipsqueak sub
direction maybe Sokka the funny and
inventive wisecracker who always has a
ton of funny lines in the show can
lighten up the mood what would you do if
they try taking me away that'd kill them
all they prey look weakest towns and
villages just don't do this there must
be another way hey man
Fire Nation is following us we make a
wrong move they'll catch him I'm sorry
didn't confuse funny and inventive with
constipated ly angry all the time he's
the biggest stick in the mud the movie
has to offer and that's saying a lot
there's a lot sticks in the mud in this
movie they're on a ship we'd need a
miracle to catch them I know you think
everything's going to work out but I
don't oh jesus boy light and oh you look
like you're gonna out a soap opera
every time you're on screen
Kevin Winston if we break him out of the
isolated sky now
but things heat up when the evil and
sinister Fire Nation arise oh we blow
like whoa oh we blow wheel all this is
Prince Zuko a firebender who is looking
to capture the avatar so he can be unban
--is-- and get his honor back from his
father the king in the show the father
burned almost half of his face off here
I think he forgot to put some block
under his eye or something taking it to
my ship if you don't come I'll burn down
this village I'll go with you
another interesting note in the movie
the Fire Nation seems very Indian or
Middle Eastern another curious choice as
the show had a much heavier lean towards
Japanese in fact their skin was lighter
than our main heroes and here it kind of
seems perplexingly reversed I don't
wanna make an unnecessary racism
argument especially seeing how an Indian
man directed this but I will it out a
very concerned and very troubled oh but
hey if you can't see the obvious
similarities between the movies designs
and the show's designs clearly you
haven't drank enough cactus juice I mean
God can you guys imagine constantly
misrepresenting characters by constantly
getting their skin colors wrong shameful
unforgivable tro sheís so Zuko comes and
takes anger way thus Sokka and Katara's
decide they have to go after him why
well again in the show it's because they
formed a strong unbreakable friendship
with him they spend time getting to know
him warmed it to his offbeat personality
and found leaked little an innocent that
they've gotten to know so well be
tortured by the Fire Nation but well
with that let's make it more
like this Dre turtle you found on the
curve of the road we found that boy he's
our responsibility we should fight I
promise I'll feed him and take him on
walks but their grandmother reveals that
Aang is in fact the avatar the only one
who can master all four elements and
communicate with the spirit world aren't
there spirits here
yes there are some spirits that live
hidden among us sure they're watching us
with great sadness or maybe that's the
audience either way great sadness Zuko
and his uncle Iroh give Aang a test and
see that all the elements gravitate
towards him even though this never
happens anywhere else in the movie but
true we have a hazily Russia escapes
scene to film which in the series
demonstrates quite clearly how the
firebenders do everything in their power
to stop them but here they just kind of
blankly stare at them getting away but
blank stares could kill they still
probably get away oh and you ever wonder
how he was frozen in that iceberg to
begin with well once again the original
ingeniously tied in both backstories of
Zuko and Aang together and show that
upon his discovery of being Avatar he
could take the pressure and ran away
being pushed to the brink of despair and
froze himself before drowning in the
storm many consider this to be the best
episode seeing how it shows the
similarities between our hero and our
villain good thing is just a sense and a
half explanation here the person talking
about doesn't even show up on screen he
told us how he left there in a storm on
Appa and got forced into the ocean where
they almost drowned long a orb ended a
sphere around them and he couldn't
remember anything after that but hey
that's just one of the minor major plot
devices that probably should have been
explored more missing also with Suki Jed
the pirates Bumi the fortune teller the
warriors of Kyoshi Sokka sense of humor
Katara strength and motherly wisdom and
any form of fun and enjoy ability that
the show was so good at bouncing out but
it's okay because we have that guy from
The Daily Show
so Aang and his team travel to his home
in the southern air temple where he
thinks he'll find the months that raised
him monkey aughts is gonna try and jump
out and scare me at any moment it's
kinda like my father this is okay if you
tell me your name
the monks named me on wait a minute you
traveled all this way all this distance
and not once did you ever ask him his
name
you know 14 you claim to be your
responsibility getting his name might be
the most important step in protecting
him imagine you do something basic like
lose him in a crowd help
I was my little boy he's my
responsibility and I can't lose in any
court well what's his name I starts with
an A I think I wasn't gonna say yes and
by the way just a fun little tidbit they
do pronounce the names different from
the show as well my name is um I'm a so
good saga my name is IDO general Iroh to
harp on this would be too hypocritical
but luckily the film gives me so much
more that I can harp on like this one
after disguising as a Jawa they come
across a boy named her room
infinitely younger in this version who
is chased for bending stones at Fire
Nation soldiers that child is being
arrested for what
he was venting tiny stones at us from
behind a tree he dared to kill a king's
death so they place them all in a prison
of earthbenders where wait up this
is the prison for earthbenders I'm sorry
I'm really sorry I know it gets really
annoying every single time I say in the
show and because it's an adaptation
adaptations they've gotta make changes I
understand that I really understand that
but it's gotta be changes that make
sense guys so in the show the prison is
on a metal ship where no earthbending is
possible and thus it breaks their spirit
because they can't get away they are
powerless to stop them here that
thereby nice stop egg makes a big speech
about rising up and fighting back we're
in the show it's justified and Katara
but still justify because there's a big
risk they have something to lose here
it's like saying walk through a
revolving door there's nothing to be
lost it's like having an ice cream
vendor at baskin-robbins and saying how
the hell my get it iced right back are
you sure in mind it's time for
you to stop doing this
sure enough they do is start fighting
back and it's about time ah let's see
some badass earth bending effects
brought to life by some state of the art
effect
is that really the extent of your
imagination
Shyamalan is that really the wide range
of possibilities that you could pull off
with this scenario earthbending
earth earth bending taking the elements
of Earth the planet and bending
it to your will and this is the poor
gasps piece of you could come
up with okay let me give you a crash
course or a reminder as someone who has
clearly seen the show what just one one
earth bender can do what that was all
one earthbender in every single one of
those scenes now let's see what tell one
two three four five five five of your
shitty-ass earthbenders from your piece
of film could accomplish
I'm a little teapot short tons don't
give baby guys get take dick no just as
a friendly reminder this is what five
guys could do in that other show you
claim to be such a big fan of
that was a tank a time five nine
nine and what did your do again
your have you no passion for possibility
have you no understanding this barrel of
Miyazaki that you could unleash with
this creativity I mean what is your
major malfunction you sucker of talent
and good what is going on in your head
please contact me let me know let me
know what the flying fox has caused you
to become so uninspired when this stuff
has practically gift-wrapped it for you
it just says make me incredible make me
incredible please did he contact with me
get it quick you have to bring balance
back faster what why turn on TV and now
a message from shovel
greetings I am Shyamalan I know many of
you were disappointed by my theatrical
addition to the Avatar franchise well
I'm here to tell you that my power to
destroy great art has grown even
stronger for you see I have discovered
how to take any performers acting
ability away he's bobbing no director is
that bad or powerful and for those who
don't think I'm that bad or powerful
just look at what I did to Mark Wahlberg
in the happening
what No Thaksin oh but that's a
critically acclaimed actor he's mastered
the art of talent betting I plan to use
this power to destroy the Avatar
franchise once and for all how you may
ask I plan on doing a Legend of Korra
movie what that's a fresh start a chance
to get a new audience rest assured the
franchise will be destroyed forever once
The Legend of Korra has been shamah
lized and for a certain avid jerk who
might be listening I have only this to
say stand down no critic has ever been
able to stop me before if you do not I
will suck out what little talent you had
to begin
that is all well critic
it seems that all hope with a franchise
rests with you great are you sure we
have the right guy
you
after discovering the aperture a new
plan has revealed that Shah Milan will
unleash his greatest evil yet - the
avatar franchise willness not a critic
and team be able to bring balance in
time and more importantly will this
review keep focus as to which series it
wishes to satirize so they're given some
bending scrolls by master Mickey Mouse
but Eng explains that he can't bend all
four elements we should go visit some of
these towns on I need to talk I ran away
before they train me lay off the
close-ups guy he looks like he's
transforming into Paul Giamatti Christ
you can practically see their breath on
the lens they're so close water comes
after air in the cycle air water earth
fire they decide now to finally go to
the North Pole to have the great masters
teach him waterbending meanwhile
commander Chow I guess is talking to
this other guy who puckers his lips so
much I swear he's waiting to be kissed
by him our spies have discovered someone
claiming to be the avatar
they described him was just a boy we
just had a trap for this person that's
all for your sake my son doesn't find
this person first wait a minute
that's the Fire Lord that's the great
badass villain in all this that's the
fun show do you think the Fire Lord was
built up big time always kept in shadow
until the final season he was like the
dr. claw of this show and when he
finally was revealed he wasn't a monster
or anything but he was still
intimidating even the picture Zuko
stares at in the film looks like the
original Fire Lord but this this this is
the most common non threatening person
you could put in this role it's like the
grabbed a guy at the grocery store and
dress them up as
Biggus Dickus Oh Shiva hell biggest dick
yes is more intimidating than him he at
least is played by an actor I know is
dead what kind of has the ghost value
it's more intimidating than this so Aang
goes on his own to the northern air
temple to see if he can find any monks
he finds a villager who shows him a room
filled with all his past lives and in my
opinion the majority of the problems
with this movie can be summed up right
here see if you can spot why how did he
have Enders no you would you have a job
come on it gave me a test about a
thousand toys in front of me and asked
me to choose four I said I chose the
same four objects I belong to the
previous of it I don't see it allow me
to explain you have a great setup for an
emotional moment and in seeing all his
past lives the power and weight of who
he is should hit him at this very point
but instead what do they do try to
explain more exposition so ceremony when
everyone boughs to me that's when I
accept my role as the other door but
when everyone bowed
I didn't bow back and that is the
problem whether you're aware of the show
or you're not aware of the show the
movie is all explanation with no
humanity why do you think they waited 20
minutes of the film to ask him his name
because that's not what was most
important to Shyamalan the identity who
gives a
it can't be nearly as important as
explaining you know I conducted a raid
on the Great Library which most said
didn't even exist and explaining there
are really powerful vendors in the
Northern Water Tribe my dad told me
about it before he left and explaining
has been confirmed that he's travelling
north
it is my strong belief that he is
traveling to the Northern Water Tribe
and explaining if we keep them to the
Courtyard in the marketplace till night
falls and you know why because I never
once heard anyone this movie saying I
feel this or I like this or I wonder
this there are no emotions being a dress
traditional storytelling is setting up a
character sending them on their journey
and learning more about them through
their journey last airbender is just
chestpiece storytelling character goes
here character goes there character says
this pawn to King four so in this scene
that should have been the emotional
pinnacle of our main star it's just more
explaining about what happened rather
than why it happened so you pardon me of
rather than be concerned when the
villager betrays him to the Fire Nation
I ask that you remind me what you
revealed about him that's worth giving
any investment whatsoever this isn't me
being angry that's different from the
show this is me being angry that's
missing the most essential element of
telling any story if the character can
never express any emotion why should the
audience ever express any emotion but
yes while we're on the subject that does
make this possibly one of the worst
adaptations of all time a show that
created such memorable characters
characters you almost believe were real
you wanted to be real you wish they were
real being portrayed as the most stock
boring empty vessels of just explaining
more plot it's about as insulting to an
adaptation as you can get by God is one
of the few times I'm glad the characters
I love so much aren't real
could you imagine them actually seeing
how they would be represented in movie
form I cringe
I saw how long the drug's kids are that
shows you how fast the
my jokes are way funnier than this the
scroll we have is proving to be helpful
almost practicing well that's just silly
I know my dad left a few days ago you're
lying I don't do that that's not what
I'm like who are you what's your name
they make me look totally stiff and
humorless I ran away from home we got in
a storm I was just upset thanks for
saving plucky I probably should yell
you're not so upset
not as much as I want horrible I'll say
no kidding you said it but the effects
were decent
thus we continue with our season one
Wikipedia recap as a character called
the Blue Spirit breaks him free and they
fight their way out
I smell a Shyamalan overlong over youth
tracking shot coming up
okay guy tracking shots are fine but
when you use them for every other fight
scene it not only gets old but it slows
the action down it's obvious the actors
have to wait for the camera to get into
place thus taking a fight sequence that
could be really quick and impressive and
instead have half of it be them just
standing around doing nothing that's why
we have editing you dumb ass jerk
if part of the shot didn't work or was
hard to see you edit it out but here
screw it I just want to show off that I
can do this in one shot okay great you
can do it
it looks cluttered slow and incredibly
awkward but you could do it give
that man a tediously obnoxious directing
award I think it's the same one that
went to this person just a few years
earlier why are you doing this who are
you
open the gates
so the Blue Spirit gets him out it is
revealed to be Zuko there's two reasons
this curious scene was left in the movie
rather than just having it cut out one
is that Shaolin Sukho are in a race to
bring the Avatar to the Firelord meaning
one of them can submit their position
forever and the other reason of course
being just so sha Millan can shout what
a twist
yeah you know that don't you think my
son is this person
the soldiers are calling the Blue Spirit
yes I recognized his mouth actually to
the film's very little credit
ciao Zuko and Iroh are probably the only
decent actors in this film they perform
their parts well and probably have the
closest thing to emotional moments this
film could muster that is before I've
cut off me Leslie for more exposition
now be sure to keep your uniform closed
up to your neck and remember your cheek
and warm
I know one god by the way nephew as your
uncle I care for you very about all four
story more stories ours or any more
story so Aang in the team finally make
their way to the North Pole
and oh god it's pissin this has gotta be
it please dummy this is even more
phallic than I imagined the stories were
true gaze into the holy grail of comedic
possibility oh my god there's too many
jokes to choose from
Oh watch it on your ways because what
should I go oh this one hey what did she
use for a headband on censor bar oh oh
thank you show the love
thank you for your unintentional
hilarity you're welcome good now
shallow
ah my blood bending should be working
it's no use
he cares nothing for the logic of this
realm so he barely follows quick critic
finish the review so you can restore
balance oh don't be so in the show Sokka
and the princess of the Northern Water
Tribe form a very powerful friendship
eventually resulting in a romance that
would ultimately end in tragedy let's
see if the movie does to my brother and
the princess became friends right away
and that's all you need yes all the
emotions that character developed can
just be summed up in that one sentence
God shell Milan's writing knows how to
cut the fat of all that pesky caring God
why do we listen to all that pesky
talking Hamlet when it could have been
summed up with the prince didn't like
his uncle high jinks ensued oh I take it
back they do have one conversation but
thankfully it's not used to develop
character form of a strong bond it's for
you guessed it more explaining when I
was born I was not awake my mother and
father could not get me to make a sound
or move they prayed for days to the moon
spirit please no more splaining she'll
say why is your hair white young lady
you look very odd I don't know why are
you so white suppose Aang and Katara
master their waterbending from Bill
Connolly Theoden and as you can see
there's no stopping their incredible
abilities now look at all that water fly
nobody there across the phenomenal power
that these two okay here's another
problem with the movie could the bending
takes forever
the original keeps the action quick and
exciting as well action should be maybe
two moves could do something impressive
but here I could heat up a hot pocket
before these guys do anything exciting
if the opening was being honest
here's how it should really go water
water water
watch but with the fire nation getting
ready to attack and the Water Tribe
ready to defend themselves with a call
that lures them into a false sense of
hilarity and tries to figure out a way
to fight them off without killing
anybody as it's not the monks way is
there a spiritual place where I can
meditate there is a very spiritual place
so he comes across the moon spirit who's
disguised as a fish yeah that wasn't the
best explained in the show either but
egg meditates to figure out an answer I
have to get back I'll take you I'll stay
with him um Katara doesn't seem like the
best person to look after him I mean
don't get me wrong in the other version
it made sense she had a kind mature
heart but also the focus it's drank to
kick some ass in several awesome scenes
nobody in the right mind would dare
cross her but in the movie she pushed a
guy
well maybe she'll finally be allowed to
show her real strength when Prince Zuko
comes and tries to take Aang away and
seeing how she made it very clear how
angers her responsibility she's gonna do
everything in her power to make sure
nothing happens to him you suck
Katara and Sokka as useful as no smoking
signs in college but Aang wakes up and
it escapes to go through the most
masterful approach possible re-enacting
a Tom and Jerry routine but things go
awry when Xiao finds the moon spirit and
kills it destroying not only the moon
but the tribes barely impressive
waterbending we have been anointed by
the moon spirit he gave me life when I
was a child and there's still a chance
but since the princess was given part of
the spirit to save her she sacrifices
her own life in order to put the moon
spirit back in its place
I can hardly explain what I'm seeing
John but the moon just came back this
resultant Shou getting axed Slumdog
Millionaire returning to his uncle and
raising the ways to scare the rest of
the army off by the way for someone who
can't kill I don't think these guys made
it out okay and to be continued that
think Jesus will never be continued
you must stop the avatar from mastering
earth and fire you must give us the time
to get to that day do you accept this
unspeakably important task I'm putting
in your hands I do father
yes I am sure as you'll join the Super
Mario Brothers Skeletor buckaroo banzai
the Golden Compass and Bisons hand in
that incredible sure to happen sequel
what a piece of oh it's not working
no he wasn't hurting him don't you have
anything else really know something
too late he's been Shama lized
hi guys I just want stand directly in
the middle of the shot and stare blankly
into the camera next ah critic it's not
too late get in contact with your other
life meditate he'll come to you as a
spirit animal quickly there's no time
okay I'll try
who come with a Syrian spirit Oh
this is my spirit animal cow
why'd I write this world so convoluted
okay whatever hi hi what do you want I
need to know how to defeat the Shama lon
oh I don't what do you mean you don't
know I don't know at a time was weeks
ago I'm reviewing Legend of Korra not
really
how's that it's okay but that's no I
haven't I guess we get down to the
victim really only need one avatar
I got it I got it
I know how to restore balance to the
franchise oh thank you platypus buddy
it's done actually platypus buddy you
saved the world I'm Walker now that's
the whole name there I'll always
remember you platypus Bonnie yeah why
did I read you so stupid
wait a minute guys I figure it out I
know how to save the franchise how do
nothing you're right we got the wrong
guy I blame myself you said no you don't
understand the franchise was never out
of balance to begin with the movie is
awful the acting is awkward the writing
beyond lazy and it fails both trying to
be a faithful adaptation and a
standalone movie but it could never be a
standalone movie because there's only
one avatar the series it was perfectly
paced perfectly performed perfectly
animated it was that rare anomaly that
chances are can never be recreated and
there's no reason to change it's like
trying to make an opera by Mozart better
you can't do it every note is where it
needs to be sure they'll be different
adaptations in the future the same way
people did with Looney Tunes or other
timeless characters but the point is the
original characters are still timeless
characters and nothing anyone can do can
change that if anything the bad
adaptation makes us appreciate the
original material even more so you can
do whatever you want to the franchise
because no matter what nothing can take
away or make any better what's already
perfect well that's great critic but
yeah still gonna do evil things oh right
right hmm how would an avatar series and
this mmm they use this machina
Hey
wait are you last airbender Aang or
Legend of Korra eh
okay wait I thought Amy wasn't allowed
to kill whatever of course I understand
what he's saying don't get to offend it
at all the changes made as long as you
still had the original to enjoy right
sure
well maybe sometimes the best way to
keep balance is to realize that balance
is already being kept
enjoy your incredibly awesome show and
enjoy hating your incredibly awful why
is your dick
Oh
are you the avatar on